und jetzt das heute journal
mit 1 wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend dass deutschland das
selbstgesetzte klimaziele für 2020 nicht
erfüllt steht außer frage
das kritisiere nicht nur klima
aktivisten die bundesregierung selbst
hat sich da ja kürzlich kollektiv
zerknirscht gezeigt und ein neues klima
paket aufgelegt drei bio landwirten
genügt das aber nicht sie sehen aufgrund
des klimawandels ihrer existenz bereits
jetzt so bedroht dass sie gemeinsam mit
ihm peace die bundesregierung verklagten
vor gericht sind sie damit jetzt
allerdings gescheitert felix zimmermann
berichtet wo einst kirschen blüten
liegen nun vier hektar gefällt die
kirschbäume seit 500 jahren baut die
familie blum aus hamburg obst an
doch mit den wärmeren sommern kamen die
kirschfruchtfliege aus dem süden wie
viel die ernte die blumes mussten die
kirschbäume fällen verloren einen großen
teil ihrer einnahmen
ich hab's ganz schlimm weil ich komme
aus einer baumschule und ich habe
gedacht das wird jetzt so weitergehen
aber irgendwann war schluss
die blums machen die bundesregierung für
den klimawandel mit verantwortlich die
hatte sich 2007 ehrgeizige ziele gesetzt
deutschland hat das ziel bis 2020 40
prozent der co2 emissionen einzusparen
und merkel hielt an diesem ziel lange
fest ich sage wir werden wege finden wie
wir bis 2020 unter 40 prozent ziel
einhalten das verspreche ich ihnen doch
vor kurzem das eingeständnis dass wir
dieses ziel war es für uns 2007
vorgenommen haben leider nicht erfüllen
werden statt der geplanten senkung der
co2-emissionen bis 2020 um 40 prozent
werden wohl nur 32 prozent erreicht
familie blumen will das nicht hinnehmen
nimmt das versprechen der
bundesregierung für mehr klimaschutz
ernst zusammen mit greenpeace und
anderen bauern verklagen sie deutschland
vor dem verwaltungsgericht berlin
die grundfrage inwiefern können gerichte
die politik zu klimaschutz zwingen
auch wenn diese noch gar keine gesetze
sondern nur ziele formuliert hat die
richter wiesen heute die klage ab die
kläger hätten keinen anspruch auf eine
andere klimapolitik das fängt an bei dem
kabinettsbeschluss der bundesregierung
dieses stellt keinen rechtlich
verbindlichen akt der außenwirkung dar
außerdem hat die bundesregierung
inzwischen diesen klimaschutzplan
aufgehoben da ich bin enttäuscht dass
das gericht nicht so viel mut bewiesen
hat dass das wirklich gesagt hat was ist
wirklich will
doch einen eigenen willen darf ein
gericht in der demokratie gar nicht
haben sondern muss das recht anwenden
und so baten die richter in der
urteilsbegründung auch um verständnis
regierung und parlament und nicht sie
seien für die klimapolitik zuständig
auch der staatsrechtler professor wie
genau sieht in solchen klima klagen eine
überforderung von gerichten
bei uns geht die staatsgewalt vom volke
aus steht im grundgesetz und eben nicht
von richtern oder von klägern oder
ähnliches wenn der parlamentarische
gesetzgeber was ich sehr hoffe schafe
klimaschutzmaßnahmen verabschiedet dann
werden wir die gerichte brauchen um
diese dann auch durchzusetzen
öko landwirt klaus blum und die übrigen
kläger können berufung gegen das urteil
einlegen
sie meinen weiter wenn die politik den
klimawandel nicht wirksam bekämpft
müssen gerichte eingreifen um
naturkatastrophen zu verhindern
die frage ob klimaschutz gegen den staat
eingeklagt werden kann wird
öffentlichkeit und gerichte noch lange
beschäftigen
die terror milizen des sogenannten
islamischen staates haben den tod ihres
anführers al baghdadi bestätigt der wahl
präsentieren die usa erstmals fotos und
videos des einsatzes vom wochenende
einzelheiten werden da aber kaum gezeigt
ein allein stehendes gebäude im norden
syriens in dem sich all back da die mit
seiner entourage auffliegt zu sehen ist
auch wie us soldaten sich dem hof nähern
und wie dann später nach dem einsatz das
gebäude aus der luft zerstört wird
was sich im inneren des hauses
abgespielt hat aber nicht erst ein us
general erklärte lediglich al bagdadi
habe sich selbst in die luft gesprengt
nicht bestätigen wollte er die
schillernden schilderungen donald trumps
er seinen bericht mit details eines
winseln und weinenden bagdad ii aus
schmückte was aber wiederum zu jumps
strategie passt von seinen aktuellen
problemen abzulenken allen voran den
drohenden amtsenthebungsverfahren ritter
hergerichtet austausch us präsident will
in seinen neuesten twitter video nochmal
zeigen was er politisch alles drauf hat
er habe jobs geschaffen illegale
migration halbiert den islamischen staat
ausgelöscht und al baghdadi getötet das
alles während die demokraten nur an
seiner amtsenthebung denken und
wirkliche probleme ignorieren würden für
die demokraten ist es ein wirkliches
problem wenn der amerikanische präsident
sein amt missbraucht ob er es getan hat
untersuchen sie seit wochen allerdings
ohne das offizielle okay des
repräsentantenhauses das holten sie
heute nach stimmten fast einstimmig für
eine entsprechende resolution
die endgültige entscheidung über eine
amtsenthebung ist damit noch nicht
gefallen
die ermittlungen gehen jetzt weiter dann
treffen wir eine entscheidung auf
grundlage der wahrheit
ich weiß nicht warum die republikaner
angst vor der wahrheit haben
jetzt gibt es neue regeln wie ermittelt
wird künftig sollen zeugenbefragungen
nicht mehr hinter verschlossenen türen
sondern öffentlich stattfinden außerdem
soll der präsident eigene zeugen zu
seiner verteidigung in die ausschüsse
schicken dürfen so wird es schwieriger
die ermittlungen wie bisher als unfair
und intransparent zu bezeichnen
mit hatte er immer wieder den boykott
der ermittlungen begründet seit wochen
droht trump abweichlern in seiner
eigenen partei brachte die republikaner
vor dem votum auf linie deren nein zur
resolution einstimmig dafür sie uns doch
mal über die inhaltliche substanz hier
reden
die demokraten haben den streit über die
regeln der untersuchung verloren
und wenn wir mal den inhalt betrachten
der präsident hat alles richtig gemacht
der präsident habe alles richtig gemacht
im juli als er mit seinem ukrainischen
amtskollegen zellen ski telefonierte und
dabei us militärhilfen an ermittlungen
gegen seinen demokratischen rivalen
biden und dessen sohn knüpfte doch viele
bisherige zeugen wollen diese version
nicht stützen am dienstag belastete
erstmals auch ein mitarbeiter des weißen
hauses dem präsidenten schwer
oberstleutnant alexander wittmann hatte
das telefonat mitgehört danach zweimal
offiziell alarm geschlagen
von jetzt an wird alles öffentlich
ausgetragen die amerikaner werden die
zeugen und details aus erster hand live
im fernsehen hören können die umfragen
haben sich schon gedreht die mehrheit
der amerikaner befürwortet die
untersuchung zur amtsenthebung ohne
termine hatte trump den tag im weißen
haus verbracht und wohl an seiner
strategie getüftelt widersprach er von
der größten hexenjagd in der
amerikanischen geschichte die aber könne
einen donald trump nicht stoppen heißt
es in seinem video
die nächsten wochen werden zeigen ob er
damit recht behält
matti wissen in washington ein
hochrangiger zeuge belasteten
präsidenten schwer aber wird eine
amtsenthebung damit tatsächlich
wahrscheinlicher
also die amtsenthebung durch das
abgeordnetenhaus ja ob am ende der senat
auch zustimmt ist eine andere frage aber
es ist ganz wichtig es handelt sich hier
um immer mehr zeugen aus einem inneren
zirkel der regierung die tatsächlich
eben berichten wie es offenbar gewesen
ist dass der präsident diese verknüpfung
militärhilfe gemacht hat als
gegenleistung für schmutzkampagne gegen
seine politischen widersacher und dass
der präsident darauf antwortet und auch
seine unterstützer darauf antwortet
indem sie versuchen die zeugen zu
beleidigen und zu beschimpfen in dem
fall dieses oberstleutnant
beispielsweise wurde er bezeichnet als
möglicher spion für die ukraine weil er
eben selber einmal in der ukraine
geboren wurde aber dieser mann ist
amerikanischer staatsbürger ist ein
kriegs hält der ist dem irak krieg
verwundet worden hat eine hohe
auszeichnung bekommen
und wenn er jetzt wie die anderen vor
der öffentlichkeit aus sagt dann wird
natürlich diese diese argumentation des
präsidenten wegfallen müssen
die öffentlichkeit wird sich dann ein
bild selber machen können von der
glaubwürdigkeit dieser zeugen
wenn das mal so auffällt eine iranische
außenpolitik verdacht auf amtsmissbrauch
attacken gegen einen verdienten
kriegshelden um ihn als zeugen zu
diskreditieren
das alles kann doch auch nicht allen
republikanern gefallen ja ich glaube man
merkt das auch daran dass die
republikaner in den letzten tagen eher
wenig in der sache argumentiert haben
also wirklich zu den inhaltlichen
vorwürfen gegen den präsidenten sondern
tatsächlich er das verfahren in den
blick genommen hat weil das eben hinter
verschlossenen türen stattfand aber auch
die republikaner müssen fürchten dass
wenn sehr klar hervor tritt dass der
präsident sein amtsmissbrauch mehr amt
missbraucht hat das sie dann in der
nächsten wahl im kommenden jahr auch
abgestraft werden könnten
ob das am ende dazu reicht das im senat
tatsächlich 20 republikaner mit den
demokraten stimmen denn nur so käme die
zweidrittelmehrheit auch für eine
entfernung des präsidenten aus dem amt
zu stande
das ist natürlich nach wie vor eine
offene frage ist hängt eben davon ab wie
glaubwürdig werden die zeugen jetzt in
der öffentlichkeit auftreten dankeschön
nach verschenkten er mattiert ist vor
diesem hintergrund ist dass verdonnert
stand natürlich umso erfreulicher mit
dem tod des terroristenführers al
baghdadi einen erfolg präsentieren zu
können zumal der rückzug der us-truppen
aus syrien auch in seiner eigenen partei
für irritation sorgte nicht nur weil man
die kurden hängen ließ die gut genug
waren so lange sie für den westen wgs
bekämpften
vor allem aber haben die usa syrien
nunmehr vollständig den russen und den
türken überlassen und den truppen des
syrischen assad regimes
was der türkische präsident erdogan
daraus machen will ist offenkundig einen
ganzen landstrich um völkern kurden raus
syrische araber ein
damit will er sein flüchtlingsproblem
und sein kurven probleme auf einen
schlag lösen
unser korrespondent jörg brase war im
türkisch syrischen grenzgebiet unterwegs
nach dem was er dort beobachtet hat
dürfte erdogans plan nur schwerlich
aufgehen
zumindest schafft er keinen frieden kurz
nachdem die türkei vor drei wochen in
nordsyrien einmarschiert war folgte die
vergeltung der kurdischen epg milizen
von der syrischen seite flogen granaten
richtung türkei
der polster laden in dem halil und sein
bruder arbeiten wurde getroffen
weiter sind syrische flüchtlinge in
akcakaya einem türkischen ort an der
grenze
wir haben hier in frieden gelebt doch
dann haben sie angefangen mit raketen
auf uns zu schießen
die leute sind alle in deckung gegangen
wir wollten die verletzten weg tragen
dann wurde auch ich durch so eine
granate getroffen
die kurdischen milizen sagt khalil
wollten sich an den türken rächen und
trafen uns flüchtlinge er bekam einen
splitter in den bauch einen in die wand
vor fünf jahren flohen er und seine
familie vor dem bürgerkrieg in die
türkei bis heute fürchtet er die macht
des syrischen regimes
ich bin aus der syrischen armee
abgehauen mein problem ist präsident
assad weil ich fahnenflucht begangen
habe wenn ich zurückgehe werde ich vor
aller augen hingerichtet weil ich an
dieser tour bin nicht nur die es leute
sind terroristen sondern auch die
soldaten von assad wir möchten das assad
regime nicht die sind noch stärker als
der e s
und nun will der türkische präsident
dass sie zurückgehen auf die syrische
seite in jene positionen in die auch us
soldaten wieder eingerückt sind sie
wollen es nicht aber fürchten dass sie
es müssen
was bleibt uns anderes übrig wenn sie
uns zwingen können wir nicht nein sagen
wenn sie entscheiden dass wir zurück
sollen können wir nichts dagegen
mehr als die hälfte der einwohner von
akdag alle sind heute syrer flüchtlinge
die oft schon seit vielen jahren in der
türkei leben sowie fässer er wurde im
kampf verletzt hat fronturlaub faysal
ist ein syrischer kämpfer der von der
türkei in den einsatz gegen die kurden
miliz epg geschickt wurde
seine truppe soll viele kurden
massakriert haben
faysal aber ist es ein kampf um seine
heimat ein zusammenleben mit den kurden
ist für ihn undenkbar
bevor ich mich der freien syrischen
armee angeschlossen habe kamen die
kurden in unser dorf und haben uns aus
unseren häusern vertrieben
sie haben unser land gestohlen und sie
haben uns zur flucht gezwungen
nein ich kann nicht in unser dorf zurück
solange die gbg dort ist kann ich nicht
dorthin zurück vor seinen truppen haben
die kurden angst seine familie hat angst
vor den kurden und andere fürchten sich
vor den truppen ersatz
es gibt keine klaren fronten in diesem
krieg keine partei ohne schuld und erst
recht keine einfachen lösungen
[Musik]
die kanzlerin ist auf dienstreise und
damit beginnen die nachrichten von
reizvoll der villa merkel ist am abend
begleitet begleitet von mehreren
ministern zu einem besuch in indien
eingetroffen bei den gesprächen geht es
unter anderem um die wirtschafts und
handelsbeziehungen und vor allem auch um
den technologieaustausch morgen sollen
zahlreiche abkommen unterzeichnet werden
deutschland ist der größte
handelspartner indiens in der eu die
polizei in nordrhein westfalen und
hessen ist einer neuen serie von
sexuellem kindesmissbrauch auf der spur
die polizei teilte mit nach dem fund von
massenweise kinderpornografische
material in einer wohnung in bergisch
gladbach seien vier männer festgenommen
worden
sie sollen kinder im alter zwischen
einem und zehn jahren missbraucht und
bilder über internet chats ausgetauscht
haben so die polizei
im streit über die umverteilung von
flüchtlingen innerhalb der eu kommt ein
gutachten des europäischen gerichtshofs
zu dem schluss dass ungarn polen und
tschechien gegen ihre verpflichtungen
aus dem unionsrecht verstoßen haben
wegen ihrer weigerung den beschlossenen
um verteilungsmechanismus umzusetzen
er war als reaktion auf die
flüchtlingskrise im sommer 2015
beschlossen worden
das gutachten ist nicht bindend häufig
folgen die richter aber der einschätzung
dort bei einem brand in einem zug in
pakistan sind mehr als 70 passagiere ums
leben gekommen drei waggons wurden
komplett zerstört mindestens 40 menschen
wurden verletzt einige von ihnen sind in
kritischem zustand
das feuer brach aus nachdem ein
gaskocher explodiert war
auf dem reisende ein essen zubereiten
wollten zu den vielen nebenwirkungen des
endlosen rexit dramas gehört dass ein
mann zu internationaler berühmtheit
gelangte den in normalen zeiten
außerhalb großbritanniens kaum jemand
kennen würde
stichwort und schon wissen sie von dem
die rede ist john burke hoch der
parlamentssprecher des londoner
unterhauses
zehn jahre lang hatte er dieses amt inne
das durchaus machtvoll ist heute wurde
burghof verabschiedet seinen rückzug
hatte er ausgerechnet auf den 31 oktober
gelegt der termin zu dem großbritannien
ja eigentlich aus der eu hätte auftreten
sollen
wenn die briten nicht wieder einmal in
die verlängerung gegangen werden aus
london
diana zimmermann ein 90 jahre alter film
hat wieder konjunktur
er sorgt für viel zuweilen bitteres
gelächter gerade heute an dem tag der ja
der pressetag sein sollte das königreich
mit am 31 oktober austreten und nix ist
der große abschied findet wieder einmal
nicht statt
das letzte mal ist es heute nur vereinen
und das ist john burke how der
parlamentspräsident berühmt umstritten
und übrigens zertifizierter tennislehrer
boris johnson schickte ihm ein
vergiftetes lob hinterher
tennisprofi in eine unkontrollierbare
tennis bei maschine haben sie
serienweise nicht zu parieren gewonnenes
und schmetterbälle produziert
john bercow selbst hat anteil daran dass
der 31 oktober nur sein großer tag ist
der brh exit hat ihm eine bühne geboten
bergbau der wortgewaltige sohn eines
taxifahrers hat sie genutzt
manche sagen missbraucht jedenfalls hat
er es verstanden dem parlament und sich
gehör zu verschaffen
oder kraftvoll verteidigte er die
abgeordneten gegen eine regierung die
sie lieber außen vor lassen oder sogar
in eine zwangspause schicken wollte
gegen die konvention erlaubte er auch
der opposition die tagesordnung zu
bestimmen abstimmungen anzusetzen dass
flieger während meiner zeit als sprecher
habe ich mich bemüht die autorität
dieser legislative zu stärken
wofür ich mich bei absoluten niemandem
irgendwo niemals entschuldigen werde
boris johnson machte zum abschied
deutlich dass er das umständlich fand
sie waren fast so erfolgreich darin die
zeit zu verlangsamen die stephen hawking
längst so impliziert johnson wäre sonst
sein plan aufgegangen europa an der
leine und großbritannien aus der union
zu führen
stattdessen ließ burger den parlaments
ältesten auch gestern quälende fragen
stellen
kann ich meinen ehrenwerten freund um
etwas klarheit bitten sollte er
zufälligerweise diese völlig
unvorhersehbaren wahlen gewinnen welche
art von beziehung strebt der an zwischen
der eu und großbritannien
die antwort blieb vage aber es ist ja
doch noch zeit bis zum großen ball bei
mindestens bis zum 31 januar
der kleine exit ist john bercow fand
pünktlich statt das parlament vor allem
die opposition wird ihn vermissen oder
oder die wirtschaftsnachrichten werden
heute von der geplanten grossfusion in
der automobilindustrie herrscht die
opel-mutter psa und fiat chrysler wollen
gemeinsam in die zukunft steuern die
konzerne gaben ihre pläne heute in einer
erklärung bekannt frank bethmann warum
gehen die beiden autobauer diesen weg
naja weil sie es müssen im immer härter
werdenden wettbewerb zählt nur noch
größer es wird geschätzt dass weltweit
nur noch platz für zehn große autobauer
sein wird erst im sommer scheiterte fiat
chryslers zusammenschluss mit renault
nissan nun scheint es zu einer fusion
mit dem opel mutterkonzern psa zu kommen
unter einem dach würden sich dann marken
wie fiat alfa romeo peugeot citroen und
opel wieder finden
es entstünde der viertgrößte autobauer
der welt größer wären dann nur noch
volkswagen toyota und renault nissan
es soll eine fusion unter gleichen
werden beide partner sollen jeweils die
hälfte an dem neuen konzern halten und
zusammen 87 millionen autos pro jahr
verkaufen
soweit die nackten zahlen doch was heißt
das für opel seit zwei jahren teil des
französischen psa-konzerns drohen jetzt
entlassungen am deutschen standorten
dass diese nachricht natürlich zunächst
einmal ängste und sorgen auslöst das
liegt auf der hand aber gerade vor dem
hintergrund ist die bedeutung des
zukunfts tarifvertrages außerordentlich
hoch er bietet den mitgliedern der ig
metall schutz vor betriebsbedingten
kündigungen bis zum 31 juli 2000 23
viele opelaner wird das vermutlich nicht
beruhigend zu hart waren die sanierungs
einschnitte in den letzten
jahren frank bethmann vielen dank in
japan ist die historische burg jury die
zum weltkulturerbe gehört durch einen
großbrand fast völlig zerstört worden
unter den niedergebrannten teilen der
burg befindet sich auch das reich
verzierte hauptgebäude aus holz verletzt
wurde niemand die brandursache ist
unklar
die burg stammt aus dem vierzehnten
jahrhundert zweiten weltkrieg war sie
schwer beschädigt und in den 90er jahren
aufwendig restauriert worden
sie sollen nun wieder aufgebaut werden
protestanten in deutschland haben heute
den reformationstag gefeiert mit
gottesdiensten hier in der lutherstadt
wittenberg erinnern sie an das wirken
martin luthers laut überlieferung soll
der augustiner mensch vor rund 500
jahren seine 95 thesen über buße und
applus an die tür der schlosskirche zu
wittenberg angeschlagen haben dadurch
leitete er die reformation ein die
schließlich zur abspaltung von der
katholischen kirche führte
vor 350 jahren ist der niederländische
maler rembrandt gestorben zum todestag
zeigt das wallraf-richartz-museum in
köln jetzt die ausstellung inside
rembrandts das museum hat 111 gemälde
aus aller welt geliebt und zu einer
großen hommage an rembrandt
zusammengetragen
wer die ausstellung sieht soll sich ein
bild machen können von dem künstler und
seinerzeit mit rembrandts ungeschönten
blick auf die menschen nächste woche
jährt sich der mauerfall jetzt zum
dreißigsten mal ein historischer tag
der aber wohl nicht mehr einfach als
deutsches jubel datum abgehakt werden
kann sondern durchaus gemischte gefühle
hervorruft in anbetracht dessen dass so
viele wähler in ostdeutschland mit dem
politischen system der bundesrepublik
offenkundig habe
die meisten schätzen aber die freiheit
die ihnen der mauerfall brachte auch
wenn der weg durch diese freiheit habt
war so erging es jedenfalls auch zwei
ostdeutschen die den neunter november 89
in berlin erlebten und den damaligen
nachrichten berichten des zdf kam
unsere autorin karin alkac die selbst
auch in der ddr aufgewachsen ist hat
ihren lebensweg danach weiter verfolgt
die der freudentaumel der ersten
ernüchterung weg bis zu ihrem heutigen
der kuh damit seit kindheit ein
sehnsuchtsort für sie vor 30 jahren kam
sabrina bernhöft aus ost berlin zum
ersten mal genau hier hier in der nacht
der nächte
als die mauer fiel also alle waren
unglaublich glücklich fühlen sich um die
hälse
da spielt es überhaupt keine rolle wo
man jetzt gerade hier kam
an der gedächtniskirche sind tausende im
freudentaumel irgendwo in der menge auch
die 18 jährige sabrina was sie damals
einer zdf reporterin sagt bis heute
zeugnis der geschichte
seit jener nacht haben wir sabrina und
andere ostdeutsche immer wieder
getroffen
ihre lebensgeschichten sind verwoben mit
diesem land freiheit und umbruch die
einstige ddr als startläuferin
schließlich jahrelang als
platzanweiserin durch lobby ihre mutter
nach der wende verliert im osten fast
jeder fünfte seine arbeit 1,6 millionen
menschen ihre bilanz eher bitter wie wir
denken noch ist im osten oder ich bin im
westen
es ging alles viel zu schnell später
zieht sie nach west berlin studiert
heiratet einen mann aus schleswig
holstein und liebt so auf ihre art die
deutsche einheit ost und west existiert
eigentlich nicht mehr so dass es schon
hat sich gut durchmischt ist auch nicht
mehr so die erste frage hast du eine ddr
vergangenheit oder kommst du aus dem
westen auch andreas rudolph feiert in
der nacht der nächte aus dem spreewald
knattert er mit seinem trabi 100
kilometer nach westberlin zum
grenzübergang heinrich heine straße
spricht einen satz der um die welt geht
die grenzöffnung springt nicht nur die
geschichte auch sein tagebuch
das ist natürlich ein anderes system
kommen wird und dass das alte sich nicht
mehr so zusammen rauben wird das war mir
klar so sagt andreas schnell den sprung
in die selbstverständlichkeit der
tontechniker aus der ddr planwirtschaft
ackert als video ticker in der
marktwirtschaft 14 stunden täglich
es ist sicherlich ein harter kampf
geworden wäre aber man wächst oder man
gibt vielleicht unter andreas hat sieben
konkurrenten in der spreewaldstadt
lübbenau über liebt arbeitet im zweitjob
noch als carl firman sowie er verdienen
ostdeutsche heute immer noch rund 15
prozent weniger als im westen
oft fragen touristen was er schätzt an
seinem leben nach 30 jahren in der ddr
und 30 jahren im vereinten land tun und
lassen zu können was man möchte
da ist noch sind große freiheit
entstanden
auch sabrina hat die chancen der
freiheit genutzt eine karriere hingelegt
im deutschen rundfunkarchiv hütet sie
das erbe des ddr-fernsehens hier kann
das alles wirklich lebendig halten dass
das nicht in vergessenheit gerät und wir
und das ist immer mein großer hoffnung
weiterhin immer davon lernen was wir
vielleicht nicht mehr machen sollten auf
keinen fall und was wir aber auch wieder
machen konnten
sabrina und auch andreas sehen sich
heute als gewinner denn erst in diesem
land meinen sie können sie ihr leben
genau so gestalten wie sie es wollen
der mauerfall ermöglichte auch der
ostdeutschen angela merkel ungeahnte
karrierewege die sich mit denen des
westdeutschen friedrich merz kreuzten
was nicht gut ausging
für ihn über den streit in der cdu
debattieren gleich maybrit illner und
ihre gäste und um 0.30 meldet sich
daniel bröckerhoff heute plus wir sind
morgen wieder da mal wieder sehen
[Musik]
und der zuschauer am ende des weges
erwartet uns morgen er das regenwetter
es wird eben windig und eben auch
regnerisch dabei und ein hochdruckgebiet
hat uns bisher den sonnenschein gebracht
aber das zieht weiter nach osten von
westen kommen die regengebiete erreichen
uns morgen schon um zehn bis in die
mitte deutschlands und bringen dann auch
ein bisschen mildere luft aus dem
südwesten mit damen mit temperatur und
schon von rund 15 grad die ziehen dann
morgen auch zu uns etwa so am oberrhein
können wir die werte erwarten am
wärmsten derzeit im süden von portugal
und spanien bis zu 25 grad am kältesten
hier oben im norden skandinaviens minus
zehn grad höchsttemperatur und frost ich
würde es auch bei uns in dieser nacht
immerhin 0 bis -6 grad wieder nur am
rhein und im südwesten bleibt es
frostfrei da ziehen morgen früh auch
schon die dicken wolken auf und es wird
dort am wärmsten auch tagsüber da sind
es dann 15 grad am oberrhein sonst aber
meist im norden und osten 6 bis 10 grad
es ist eine zweiteilung am vormittag da
haben wir im osten noch das sonnige
wetter im westen sind die wolken dicht
und ab und zu regnet zu formen zurück
wir sind sauer land hinein und
nachmittags haben die wolken auch die
mitte dann am späten nachmittag abend
auch den osten erreicht es wird immer
wieder leicht regnen viel das ist wohl
wahrscheinlich nicht und wir haben einen
kräftigen südostwind dazu das wetter
geht weiter mild wird der samstag dazu
windig und auch schaurig kann man sagen
und das setzt sich sonntag und auch am
montag fort ich wünsche euch noch einen
schönen abend und macht es gut